when Marco Laura finishes working on an
engine it'll never growl again some five
years ago he began converting
automobiles to electric power it's a
lucrative business he can convert almost
any car he gets the kids he needs from
China another manga scan for we do it
very simply we take out the internal
combustion engine here and mount an
electric motor everything else stays the
same from the braking system to the
clutch which makes it easy for drivers
because they don't have to readjust they
can shift like always with a clutch and
that also makes the conversion
affordable high almost went us was on
affordable means from ten to fifteen
thousand euros that includes the lithium
storage batteries they are usually
installed here in the space where the
spare tire when otherwise go if you loan
there's a lot of curvature here which
makes it harder to work with we're
losing a lot of space some fits in furs
he's got another ten to install in this
car there may be space underneath the
vehicle it takes a total of thirty
batteries to give an electric car the
range customers demand among the fecking
if you plan your route efficiently you
can easily drive a hundred kilometers
there and a hundred kilometers back no
problem at all once you've got fast
charge installed you can generally
recharge in about two hours
for Marco Laura every customer and every
conversion is unique but that's nothing
new his family's business in offenbach
used to build machines primarily for the
textile industry but the point came when
that traditional specialization just
didn't earn enough
midler violets stem declined more and
more of the small enterprises that were
our principal clients are dying out we
could be very flexible with the lawn but
a lot of them have out sourced abroad
and we couldn't keep up anymore about
two years ago marcola I converted this
old VW Beetle the electric motor has
kept going and going and going the
owners here just to renew the inspection
sticker the kids are thrilled because
the car doesn't make any noise anymore
and people at the side of the road often
stare or wave at us older people who are
familiar with the beetle know the engine
was really loud and they always look
pretty baffled but if they can't figure
out why it's not making any noise Marco
larai owns a small fleet of electric
cars he might drive his mini or for
example this 40-year old Saab that he
converted himself the power for a
hundred kilometres costs only four euros
the fuel for a conventional engine would
cost three times as much
but he hasn't had to worry about fuel
prices for years try so garnish male
some title of you doctor often I don't
even know what the current fuel prices
are I just don't pay attention anymore
whenever I need to fill up for some
reason I have to ask someone what the
prices are on nowadays his customers
could tell similar stories converting
help save money and the environment but
not time on the highway with speeds
topping out around 120 km/h but that
doesn't faze the real ecar fans